This is Ira Glass, host of Your Radio Playhouse , and starting this week, WBEZ is moving the program that usually begins right at this time, Selected Shorts , to Friday nights at 8 o'clock. So if you want hear Selected Shorts tune in on Fridays at 8:00.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，是《你的广播剧场》的主持人。从本周开始，WBEZ电台将把通常在这个时间播出的节目《精选短篇》调整到每周五晚上8点播出。所以，如果您想收听《精选短篇》，请在周五晚上8点锁定频道。
And WBEZ is rebroadcasting my Friday night program, Your Radio Playhouse , right here, right now after Prairie Home Companion . And there's a little radio programming experiment. The idea is that since my program is radio storytelling plus music, it has some things in common with Prairie Home Companion , and might be the kind of thing that Garrison Keillor fans would enjoy. WBEZ is going to try this out for a few months and WBEZ management welcomes your thoughts and reactions to this programming idea.
WBEZ电台目前正在《草原家园伴侣》之后，重播我在周五晚上的节目《你的广播剧场》。这是一个小小的广播节目实验。我们的想法是，既然我的节目结合了广播故事和音乐，它与《草原家园伴侣》有共通之处，可能也是加里森·基勒的粉丝会喜欢的类型。WBEZ电台打算尝试几个月，管理层欢迎您对这一节目构想提出想法和反馈。
Your Radio Playhouse has been on the radio on Friday nights now for several months, and if you haven't heard it, the stories are told in a wide variety of styles by a wide variety of writers and performers. And some of the program just happens right here in the radio studio.
《你的广播剧场》在周五晚上已经播出了好几个月了。如果您还没听过，节目中的故事是由各种各样的作家和表演者以多种风格讲述的。而且，节目中的一部分内容就在这个广播演播室里即兴发生。
For example, this week's program is about love. It's for the week of Valentine's Day. And we begin with this cassette-- I have it here-- that a friend sent me for the Valentine's Day holiday. This is "A Guided Meditation For Singles" presented by Frayda Kafka. And normally, if you're going to make something like this up, you actually would give the person-- you'd make up a name like Frayda Kafka. But I'm afraid this all too real. Frayda Kafka, produced by something called Conscious Singles Connection Incorporated, copyright 1994.
例如，本周的节目主题是爱情，正值情人节这一周。我们从这盘卡带开始——我把它带来了——这是一个朋友送给我的情人节礼物。这是由弗雷达·卡夫卡带来的《单身人士引导式冥想》。通常情况下，如果你要编造这种东西，你可能会给当事人取个像弗雷达·卡夫卡这样的名字。但我担心这实在是太真实了。弗雷达·卡夫卡，由“意识单身连接公司”制作，版权所有1994年。
And this cassette has lots of ideas for things that singles-- conscious singles, presumably-- can do so they don't feel bad on holidays like Valentine's Day.
这盘卡带里有很多点子，供单身人士——据推测是那些有意识的单身人士——在情人节这样的节日里可以做的事情，这样他们就不会感到难过。
You know, you can give yourself a very special day alone if that's what you're going to do with your holiday. You can prepare for it, actually prepare in advance. You can buy flowers for yourself. You can light candles. You can plan a special ritual, a special meal just for you. You can even write yourself letters about it, poems. You can listen to very wonderful music on that day.
你知道，如果你打算一个人过节，你可以为自己安排一个非常特别的单身日。你可以为此做准备，真正地提前准备。你可以为自己买花，可以点蜡烛，可以为自己策划一个特别的仪式，一顿特别的餐点。你甚至可以为此给自己写信、写诗。那天你可以听非常美妙的音乐。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's Your Radio Playhouse . I'm Ira Glass. And you know, you didn't have to prepare in advance for this hour. We have prepared the whole thing for you. We have set the table. We've lit the candles. It's all set. Oh, conscious singles. And couples, you couples who are sensitive to your consciously single friends. A very special hour for you, so stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。你知道吗，你们不需要为这一个小时提前做任何准备。我们已经为您准备好了一切。我们已经摆好了餐桌，点燃了蜡烛。一切就绪。哦，有意识的单身人士们。还有情侣们，你们这些对单身朋友保持敏感的情侣们。这是一个为您准备的特别节目，请继续收听。
What's amazing about this tape to me is its utter lack of modesty about what it promises. It doesn't just promise to make you feel a little better about being single, it is categorical. It promises complete spiritual and emotional peace. When you're done listening to this cassette it says, "You will be at peace with being single. You will feel happy. You will feel fulfilled."
这盘录音带让我感到惊奇的是，它对自己的承诺完全没有谦逊可言。它不仅仅承诺让你对单身感觉好一点，它是绝对的。它承诺给予完全的精神和情感上的平静。它说，当你听完这盘卡带，“你将与单身状态达成和解。你会感到快乐。你会感到满足。”
And you know you can do it by simply relaxing.
而且你知道，你只需要放松就能做到这一点。
You know what could be easier? What could be easier?
你知道还有什么更容易的吗？还有什么比这更容易的呢？
All you need to do is pay attention to your breath.
你所需要做的仅仅是关注你的呼吸。
This isn't-- I don't know, it's not working for me. Are you breathing there at home? Are you? If you're in your car, are you breathing right now? And is it happening, are you finding peace?
这并不是——我不知道，这对我没用。你们在家里呼吸了吗？呼吸了吗？如果你在车里，你现在在呼吸吗？这有效果吗，你找到平静了吗？
She also says this sentence, which I love.
她还说了这样一句话，我很喜欢。
And the rest is up to me.
剩下的就由我来决定了。
That is a sentence you never hear in the English language. Usually when people get into the construction and the rest is up to-- that's a pretty common construction in school, in sales situations, over the TV. You hear that a lot and people never go into the construction, and the rest is up to-- and end up with me. No, it's always you.
这是你在英语中永远听不到的一句话。通常当人们用到“剩下的就由……”这个句式时——这在学校、销售场景或电视上是很常见的句式。你经常听到这个说法，但人们从来不会在“剩下的就由……”之后接上“我”。不，总是“你”。
And the rest is up to me.
剩下的就由我来决定了。
She also says this other thing that I find mesmerizing, but incomprehensible. And it's this--
她还说了另一件让我觉得着迷但又不可思议的事情。就是这个——
You don't even need to listen.
你甚至不需要去听。
What is that about? You know, she's in the tape business. It's not like a video thing, it's a cassette with sound.
这是什么意思？你知道，她是做磁带生意的。这又不是视频，这是一盘有声音的卡带。
You don't even need to listen.
你甚至不需要去听。
If at the beginning of our radio show we would say to you, hi, we've been working really hard to prepare a really good show for you. And there's one other thing you've got to know--
如果我们在广播节目开始时对你说：“嗨，我们一直在努力为您准备一个非常好的节目。还有一件事你必须知道——”
You don't even need to listen.
你甚至不需要去听。
Unless it was some sort of reverse psychology thing. You know what I mean? We've used all the promotional tactics we could think of and now we're doing reverse psychology. We're doing reverse psychology and what we're saying is--
除非这是一种逆向心理战。你明白我的意思吗？我们用尽了能想到的所有促销策略，现在我们在用逆向心理学。我们是在玩逆向心理学，我们想说的是——
You don't even need to listen.
你甚至不需要去听。
Yeah, that will be the day. So side one of the tape is a kind of warm-up to the actual meditation, and side two is the guided meditation itself.
是的，真有那天的话。所以磁带的第一面是实际冥想之前的热身，第二面是引导式冥想本身。
And she has us relax, breathe deeply, which we have all been practicing earlier in the show. And then she says, pretend you're having a dream. And the dream she has us pretend is astonishingly banal. You pretend we're floating among clouds.
她让我们放松，深呼吸，这我们在节目早些时候都已经练习过了。然后她说，假装你在做梦。而她让我们假装做的那个梦简直平庸得惊人。你假装我们在云中漂浮。
And you can let that cloud carry you, spiraling up over the roof. Floating over the trees. Way up over the mountains.
你可以让那朵云带着你，盘旋在屋顶之上。漂浮在树林之上。高高地漂浮在群山之上。
If you had to pay for dreams, this is one you wouldn't even rent. You wouldn't even rent this one at the video store.
如果你必须为梦付费，这一个你甚至不会去租。你甚至不会在录像带店租这个梦。
So you float in the dream, and of course because all the elements have to be involved, there's air and there's clouds, and you float passed the mountain. And then you come, of course, to a river. And this is where she gets to the heart of the matter. Remember the promise of the tape is that she is going to make you feel good about your singlehood, and at peace with it. And how does she do it?
所以你在梦中漂浮，当然因为所有元素都必须参与其中，有空气，有云朵，你漂浮着经过了山脉。然后，当然，你来到了一条河流。这就是她切入问题核心的地方。记住，这盘卡带的承诺是让你对单身状态感觉良好，并与之和平共处。她是怎么做到的呢？
It's really fascinating. She does it by having you imagine the person who you're meant to be with.
真的很令人着迷。她让你想象那个你注定要在一起的人，从而实现这一点。
This person understands you and loves you and knows exactly what to say to you.
这个人理解你、爱你，并且确切地知道该对你说什么。
In other words, the whole way that you're going to come to peace with your singlehood is you just envision the day when you're not single. That seems like kind of a cheat to me. That isn't being at peace with singlehood. That's simply believing that your singlehood is a temporarily delayed state that will lead to couplehood.
换句话说，你与单身状态达成和解的全部方式，就是预想那个你不再单身的某一天。这在我看来有点像作弊。那不是与单身状态达成和解。那仅仅是相信你的单身状态是一个暂时延迟的状态，最终会走向双人状态。
This person can be male or female. It may not even really be a person.
这个人可以是男性，也可以是女性。甚至可能根本不是一个人。
What is that about? What is the bet that she's hedging there? Like, you know, who is she trying not to offend? Like, OK, we've got the people who are involved with the males. We've got the people involved with the females. And then, we just want to be sure like we get everybody in, the people who are involved with-- what, a horse?
这是什么意思？她在打什么埋伏？就像，你知道，她试图不冒犯谁？比如，好吧，我们有和男性交往的人，我们有和女性交往的人。然后，我们只是想确保把每个人都包括进去，那些和——什么，马交往的人？
And this person will come as close to you as you wish. And touch you in any way that feels good for you. Take your time now and let yourself feel the way you'd like to be touched. You might like just a touch on the shoulder, or an arm around you. You might like a hand on your forehead. Or maybe you'd like to be held or rocked. You can have whatever you want from this person.
而这个人会尽可能地靠近你，以任何让你感觉良好的方式触碰你。现在花点时间，让自己感受一下你希望被怎样触碰。你可能只是喜欢肩膀上的触摸，或者被一只手臂环绕。你可能喜欢手放在额头上。或者你可能喜欢被拥抱或摇晃。你可以从这个人身上得到你想要的任何东西。
At this point in the tape, I have to say-- for me, anyway-- it kind of starts to work on me. I start to think, like yes, I do want this person who's going to hold me and be the person who totally understands me.
在磁带的这一点上，我必须说——至少对我来说——它开始对我起作用了。我开始想，是的，我确实想要这样一个人，他会拥抱我，成为那个完全理解我的人。
This person is here for you from your future.
这个人从你的未来来到这里。
And one of the things that's interesting to me about this is not just that it's so effective, but that it's such a lie. I mean, if you've ever been in an actual relationship, no human being who you're going to be with is going to be there to touch you the way you want to be touched every time, and talk to you the way you want to be talked to every time.
关于这一点，让我感兴趣的不仅是它如此有效，而且它是一个谎言。我的意思是，如果你曾经真正处于一段关系中，你所陪伴的任何一个人都不可能每次都以你想要的方式触碰你，也不可能每次都以你想要的方式跟你说话。
And the fact that this could be a comfort to someone, I think it's just a sign of how much we want this. You know, that we want this person.
事实证明这能给某人带来安慰，我认为这只是说明我们有多么渴望这一点。你知道，我们是多么渴望这个人。
In the New Yorker magazine this week, John Updike writes about Lana Turner's seven husbands. He says, there's something ridiculous about a woman who take seven husbands. As if she had rummaged through the drawers of masculinity and come up with seven dwarfs.
本周的《纽约客》杂志上，约翰·厄普代克写到了拉娜·特纳的七任丈夫。他说，一个结过七次婚的女人有些可笑。就好像她在男性的抽屉里翻找，结果找出了七个小矮人。
And I think that actually, what's ridiculous about it isn't that there was anything wrong with those seven guys that they were dwarfs. What's ridiculous is the notion that she could be married to seven different people and be happy with none of them. That she, herself, would not be able to find happiness with any of those guys.
我认为实际上，这可笑的地方不在于那七个人有什么问题导致他们成了小矮人。可笑的是那种认为她可以和七个不同的人结婚却一个都不快乐的想法。她自己无法与这些人中的任何一个找到幸福。
And the reason why she didn't find happiness with those guys was cause she was waiting for another guy. She was waiting for the guy on this cassette who doesn't exist.
她没有与那些人找到幸福的原因，是因为她在等待另一个人。她在等待这盘卡带上的那个根本不存在的男人。
You know, what do we do with that dream? The dream that love is going to knock at the door. Like in some melodrama. Like a TV soap opera. What do we do about it when we've heard love call before and watched ourselves mess it up? What do we do?
你知道，我们该拿那个梦怎么办？那个爱情会敲门的梦。就像在某些情节剧中。就像电视肥皂剧一样。当我们曾经听到过爱的呼唤，却看着自己搞砸了它时，我们该怎么办？我们该怎么办？
In this hour, that dream and the difficulty of that dream.
在接下来的这一小时里，我们将探讨那个梦以及那个梦的困境。
[MUSIC- "LOVE AND HAPPINESS" BY REV. AL GREEN]
[音乐 - 阿尔·格林牧师的《爱与幸福》]
Well, our special pre-Valentine's Day love program in three acts. Act one, Yearning, with setbacks. Act two, Sex and Sex and Sex. Act three, A Wedding.
那么，我们特别的情人节爱情节目分为三幕。第一幕：渴望，伴随着挫折。第二幕：性，性，还是性。第三幕：婚礼。
Act one, Yearning.
第一幕：渴望。
We begin with this image, a woman in a crushed red velvet dress, lying on her stomach on the ground. The dress has a train that's 60 feet long trailing behind her. Her face looks like the face of someone who's been making out in the backseat of a car for hours. Her mouth is swollen and puffy from kissing. Lipstick is smeared everywhere, on her mouth and chin. A dab is on her nose.
我们以这个形象开始：一个穿着压碎的天鹅绒红裙的女人，肚子贴地躺在地上。裙子后面拖着一条60英尺长的裙摆。她的脸看起来像是在汽车后座缠绵了几个小时的人的脸。她的嘴因为亲吻而肿胀红肿。口红到处都是，嘴上、下巴上。鼻子上也沾了一点。
She's kissing the ground, methodically, with purpose. She kisses the ground, applies a fresh coat of lipstick, kisses again. Applies another color, kisses again. She's gone through 11 tubes of lipstick in 25 hours. There's that sweet lipsticky perfume in the air.
她有条不紊地、有目的地亲吻着地面。她亲吻地面，补上一层新鲜的口红，再亲吻。换个颜色，再亲吻。在25个小时里，她用了11支口红。空气中弥漫着那种甜甜的口红味。
She's spelling out words on the floor in lipstick. Each letter is two feet high.
她用口红在地上拼写文字。每个字母有两英尺高。
The word's say, there was a time when I worshipped the ground you walked on.
文字写道：曾经有一段时间，我崇拜你走过的每一寸土地。
I'm making a monument to my ex-boyfriend.
我正在为我的前男友建立一座纪念碑。
The woman's named Julie Laffin, and the ex-boyfriend she says, was everything she wanted to be-- creative, together. She said she did worship the ground he walked on. She said she was the kind of person who was always in love with the fantasy of being in love.
这个女人名叫朱莉·拉芬，她说那个前男友曾是她想成为的一切——有创造力、为人稳重。她说她确实崇拜他走过的土地。她说她那种人总是沉溺于“沉溺于恋爱”的幻想中。
And I've worked really hard to maintain that fantasy in the face of all information about reality, the reality of the situation.
为了维持那种幻想，我面对所有关于现实的信息——那种情况的现实，付出了巨大的努力。
When she first started kissing the ground, in public, as performance art, a part of her wished that the ex-boyfriend would find out. Maybe he would see that she had put him behind her. Maybe he'd have regrets. Maybe he'd get in touch with her. Who among us has not known this particular mix of conflicting feelings towards an ex?
当她第一次开始作为行为艺术在公共场合亲吻地面时，她内心一部分希望前男友能发现。也许他会看到她已经把他抛在脑后了。也许他会后悔。也许他会联系她。我们中间谁没有对前任有过这种复杂的矛盾情感呢？
Julie Laffin moved onto other kissing projects.
朱莉·拉芬转向了其他的亲吻项目。
I kissed all the names of my ex-lovers onto public property. I kissed the names on parking meters and benches and sidewalks and glass windows. And when I kiss their names, I actually would flash to that person and really dwell on them. And it was this very kind of releasing activity.
我把所有前任的名字都亲吻在了公共设施上。我把名字印在停车计时器、长椅、人行道和玻璃窗上。当我亲吻这些名字时，我确实会闪回到那个人的身上，真正地沉浸在关于他们的回忆中。这是一种非常具有释放感的活动。
When I got to the last person's name, I kissed it onto this big, concrete wall. And I thought, this is the last person in my life. This is the last relationship that I've had. This is actually the last relationship I will ever have. And I sort of saw myself as now I was going to take this role of the eternal spinster.
当我亲吻到最后一个人的名字时，我把它印在一堵巨大的水泥墙上。我想，这是我生命中的最后一个人。这是我拥有的最后一段关系。这实际上是我这辈子唯一一段最后的爱情。我把自己视为那个永恒的老处女。
When she does these performance art pieces, kissing the ground, she says that sometimes she feels like this nonentity. People stand near her, talk about what she's doing as if she's not there. And when she leaves, they walk on the words she's made with her mouth, turn them into a big red blur on the ground.
当她进行这些行为艺术表演，亲吻地面时，她说有时她感觉自己像个透明人。人们站在她附近，谈论她的行为，仿佛她不存在一样。当她离开时，他们踩在她用嘴唇写下的文字上，把它们变成地面上一团模糊的红色。
And Julie Laffin says there's something about kissing, compulsively for hours, that's partly like being out of control and partly very peaceful. Meditative.
朱莉·拉芬说，连续几个小时强迫性地亲吻，有一种既像是失控，又像是非常平静、冥想般的感觉。
She slides along the ground, kissing out the pattern of each letter.
她沿着地面滑动，亲吻出每个字母的图案。
The other day, this guy came in selling peanuts for the homeless. And he walked in and he said, is this what I think it is? And I said, I don't know. What do you think it is? And he said, are these all lip marks? And I said, yes. And he said, I wish I were the guy that these were meant for.
前几天，有个家伙进来卖花生给无家可归者。他走进来问：“这是我想的那样吗？”我说：“我不知道。你觉得是什么？”他说：“这些全是唇印吗？”我说：“是的。”他说：“真希望我就是那个这些唇印为之而生的人。”
There's a yearning for love that we feel when we've actually loved someone and been loved. And then there's the yearning for love that you feel if you have it. Mark  O'Brien is a writer in California, but because of a childhood case of polio, he lives most of each day in an iron lung on his back. He's the subject of this amazing little film, new film, called Breathing Lessons. And the film is remarkable because it's about a guy in an iron lung, but it is completely unsentimental.
当我们真正爱过某人并被爱过时，会感受到一种对爱的渴望。如果你拥有爱，你会感受到另一种渴望。马克·奥布莱恩是加利福尼亚的一位作家，由于童年时患过小儿麻痹症，他每天大部分时间都躺在背后的铁肺里。他是一部名为《呼吸课》的令人惊叹的小型新纪录片的主角。这部片子非常了不起，因为它讲述的是一个生活在铁肺中的人，但却完全不感伤。
And in certain moments, it's also pretty funny. The film is by Jessica Yu, and it was just at the Sundance Film Festival. And Jessica Yu gave us permission to excerpt a memorable little scene from the film here on our radio show.
在某些时刻，它也非常有趣。这部电影由杰西卡·余执导，刚刚在圣丹斯电影节展出。杰西卡·余允许我们在我们的广播节目中节选电影中一个令人难忘的小片段。
Because he's in the iron lung, Mark O'Brien has attendants cook and help him out during the day. And during the film he explains that these days he always has men do this job. Because when he had women do the job, he kept falling in love with them. And the love was never reciprocated. He wrote about one of these women, "Her pale, perfect skin, her strong, fleshy legs drove me to ecstasies of despair. See, she'd talk with me as a human instead of her savagely crippled employer."
因为他生活在铁肺里，马克·奥布莱恩白天需要护理人员做饭并帮助他。在影片中，他解释说，现在他总是雇佣男性来做这份工作。因为当他雇佣女性时，他总是会爱上她们，而这种爱从未得到回应。他曾写到过其中一位女性：“她苍白、完美的皮肤，强壮、丰满的双腿让我陷入了绝望的狂喜。你看，她和我谈话是把我当成一个人，而不是她那严重残疾的雇主。”
Here's a little scene about desire and yearning from this film.
这是影片中关于欲望和渴望的一小段场景。
I hired a sex surrogate in '87 or '86. I forget when. I felt very crazy. I was angry at all women for not falling in love with me because I'd fallen in love with several attendants and they all said it was a business relationship. A sex surrogate is a person who has some psychological training that works with their body, having sex with a client who is referred by a therapist.
我在87年或86年雇佣了一位性代理人。我不记得是什么时候了。我感到非常疯狂。我生所有女人的气，因为她们没有爱上我，因为我爱上了好几个护理员，她们都说这只是生意关系。性代理人是一个经过心理训练，通过身体与客户进行性行为的人，这是由治疗师推荐的。
The surrogate had this big mirror and she showed me naked and aroused. I thought of myself as the ugliest man in the world. But it's like something, someone who would want to have sex with. Not just my dick, but my whole body.
那位代理人有一面大镜子，她让我看到自己赤身裸体且产生性欲的样子。我曾认为自己是世界上最丑的男人。但这就像某种东西，有人愿意与之发生性关系的人。不仅仅是我的阴茎，而是我的整个身体。
And Carol was very kind to me. She kissed me on the chest after we had intercourse. I felt my chest was very unattractive, but she kissed me right there and the intercourse was so quick. I hate to say it, but it was wham, bam, thank you, ma'am. And it wasn't as great as I thought it would be, but being naked in a bed with a woman who's being extremely friendly was the most fun I've ever had. I think I'd like to do it again.
卡萝尔对我非常友善。我们在性交后，她亲吻了我的胸部。我觉得我的胸部非常缺乏吸引力，但她就在那里亲吻了我，而且性交时间非常短。我不想说，但那真是“嘿咻一下，谢谢大姐”。虽然不像我想象的那样完美，但在床上赤身裸体地和一个极其友好的女人在一起，是我经历过最快乐的事。我想我愿意再做一次。
Usually Mark O'Brien can't be outside of his iron lung for more than 45 minutes. But when the sex surrogate was with him, he was outside his tube for longer than that. Longer than he almost ever goes out. And he didn't even use his portable respirator.
通常马克·奥布莱恩离开铁肺的时间不能超过45分钟。但当那位性代理人与他在一起时，他离开呼吸管的时间比那还要长。比他几乎任何时候出门的时间都长。而且他甚至没有使用便携式呼吸机。
I didn't need it for an hour. I went for an hour without it. They should think of sex as respiratory therapy. Maybe Medicare would pay for it.
我有一个小时不需要它。我离开它一个小时。他们应该把性视为呼吸治疗。也许医疗保险会为此买单。
About a year after I last saw her, I just felt terribly depressed. I expected somehow that seeing the surrogate would change my life. I'd started wearing cologne and I thought everyone would be able to tell I was sexy and handsome. But nothing happened. They tell us to think of ourselves as sexual and beautiful, but it doesn't do any good unless someone else sees us as sexual and beautiful. You just can't demand love. You have to be lovable. I'm still trying to figure out how to do that.
在我最后一次见到她大约一年后，我感到非常沮丧。我原本期待见到那位代理人会改变我的生活。我开始喷古龙水，以为每个人都能看出来我很性感、很英俊。但什么也没发生。他们告诉我们要认为自己是性感和美丽的，但除非别人也这样看你，否则毫无用处。你不能强求爱。你必须是一个值得爱的人。我还在努力弄明白怎么做到这一点。
This is Luis Rodriquez and the piece is called "Waiting."
这是路易斯·罗德里格斯的作品，题目是《等待》。
What made the waiting so painful? The woman had called, she was on her way.
是什么让等待变得如此痛苦？那个女人打过电话，说她在路上了。
Tense, I waited sitting at the kitchen table. There had been too many nights waking up to bottles and books on the floor. Two small children parked on blankets in the corner.
我紧张地坐在餐桌旁等待。有过太多次在瓶子和书本散落一地的地板上醒来的夜晚。两个小孩在角落里的毯子上睡着。
Alone ain't so bad. Dreams of women yet to be touched, to be smelled. It ain't bad.
独自一人也并不坏。梦想着尚未被触碰、尚未被闻到的女性。那并不坏。
Up on a hill hidden by wood and shingled shacks alongside curbless roads visited by nobody unless they had to be here. Alone ain't so bad.
在山上，隐藏在木头和木瓦小屋旁，沿着没人光顾的没有路缘的道路。独自一人也并不坏。
Hammering holes into walls with fists, tears streaming down my face at saxophone riffs. Looking at old photos, feeding babies, taking out trash, and thinking of her. It ain't so bad. I couldn't stand it.
用拳头在墙上砸出洞，听着萨克斯的乐句眼泪直流。看着旧照片，喂孩子，倒垃圾，想着她。那并不坏。我简直无法忍受。
Looked through personal ads in the weeklys. Made phone calls, wrote letters, came across a video date, the godsend for lonely people. I called. After three false starts, a lady said she would be here Saturday. It's Saturday and I'm going nuts.
翻看周刊上的个人征友广告。打电话，写信，碰到了视频约会，这是给孤独者的天赐之物。我打了电话。经过三次失败的尝试，一位女士说她周六会来。现在是周六，我要疯了。
An hour finding the place, an old stucco white basement room. You can't miss it. Cholo graffiti on the front door. She came, made her pits. Saw the hurt in my eyes. I always spoke with my eyes, dammit. A longing for sweet companionship. Not of drunken home boys or angel dusted street women, for the mother of my kids out at Sunny's Lounge sucking Kahluas and highballs, and shooting out wicked smiles at discoed-out dudes.
花了一个小时才找到那个地方，一个老式的灰泥白色地下室房间。你不会错过的。前门上有涂鸦。她来了，摆出姿势。看到了我眼里的伤痛。我总是用眼睛说话，该死。一种对甜蜜陪伴的渴望。不是醉醺醺的狐朋狗友，也不是嗑药的街头女人，而是我孩子们的母亲，在桑尼酒廊喝着卡鲁瓦咖啡甜酒和烈酒，对着那些迪斯科打扮的男人露出邪恶的微笑。
The lady looked in my eyes and then stopped. Refused to sell me the video date. Refused to take the check. This can't help you, she said, and walked out.
那位女士看着我的眼睛，然后停了下来。拒绝卖给我视频约会。拒绝收那张支票。“这帮不了你，”她说，然后走了出去。
He asked me to go for a walk. I said no, even though I knew I wanted to.
他让我去散步。我说不，尽管我知道我内心想去。
This story about wanting love from Dolores Wilbur.
这个关于渴望爱的故事来自多洛莉丝·威尔伯。
We were sweeping out the cottage, cleaning up. It was time to go home. We had to leave that afternoon, less than a couple of hours away.
我们在打扫小屋，清理东西。该回家了。那天下午我们要离开，不到几个小时就要走。
He just looked at me without expression, not sure of how he should look. He knew I would go for a walk. He knew I wanted to.
他只是面无表情地看着我，不确定该表现出什么神情。他知道我会去散步。他知道我想去。
I knew I would as well, but I wanted to say no to try it out. I gave in almost immediately. So we walked. I kicked stones watching my feet. There were trees on either side of us.
我也知道我会去的，但我还是想说不，试探一下。我几乎立刻就妥协了。于是我们散步。我踢着石头，看着自己的脚。我们两侧都是树。
He said, I don't have anything to say. I just wanted to walk with you.
他说，我没什么可说的。我只是想和你走走。
I said stupid things. Or maybe it is that they weren't stupid, but saying them out loud sounded so stupid.
我说了一些愚蠢的话。或者也许不是愚蠢的话，但大声说出来听起来太蠢了。
He said, how do you feel?
他说，你感觉怎么样？
I said, upset. He  nodded. I hated that he nodded. He knew it was going badly and he began to feel miserable. He tried to think of something to say.
我说，很难受。他点了点头。我讨厌他点头。他知道事情进展得很糟，他开始感到难过。他努力想说些什么。
I said, I don't understand you. We thought we were alike, but we find we are not. I hate when you say you're sorry you hurt my feelings. You didn't hurt my feelings, you hurt me. And you're dumb. Why are you doing this? I hate this conversation. I hate this kind of conversation.
我说，我不理解你。我们以为我们很像，但发现我们并不像。我讨厌你说你很抱歉伤害了我的感情。你没有伤害我的感情，你伤害了我。你真笨。你为什么要这么做？我讨厌这场对话。我讨厌这种对话。
He said, I hate this conversation too. I hate it so much.
他说，我也讨厌这场对话。我太讨厌它了。
I said, well, you're the man. You're the one making it all wrong. You figure it out.
我说，好吧，你是男人。是你把一切都搞错了。你自己去解决吧。
He said, I'm the one who's supposed to fix it, is that it?
他说，我是那个应该去解决它的人，是这样吗？
I said, we can't be friends. We can't. I can't. It's not what I want.
我说，我们不能做朋友。我们不能。我做不到。这不是我想要的。
He nodded, looked down, looked away. Looked anxious, afraid to say anything.
他点了点头，低下头，移开目光。看起来很焦虑，害怕说什么。
After a while he said, how you feel now, this has happened to me before.
过了一会儿，他说，你现在感觉如何，这种事以前也发生在我身上。
What? I said.
什么？我说。
He told me something that only made me mad. He wanted someone who didn't want him and it took a long time to be over. So what, I thought. Who cares? It's not the same.
他告诉我的一些事只会让我更生气。他曾经想要一个不想要他的人，那花了很长时间才走出来。那又怎样，我想。谁在乎呢？这不一样。
He said, can't we be friends?
他说，我们不能做朋友吗？
We can talk on the phone, but we can't see each other, I said.
我们可以通电话，但不能见面，我说。
But will we talk to be friends? He said.
但我们要为了做朋友而交流吗？他说。
No, I said.
不，我说。
He said, what will we say? Hi, how are you? I'm fine. That's all?
他说，我们要说什么？嘿，你好吗？我很好。就这样吗？
I don't know, I said.
我不知道，我说。
We walked aimlessly. It was hot. We looked for shade. He stopped at a bunch of rocks marking the gate in front of a white picket fence. He picked up one of the rocks with both hands. It was big and rough, salt and pepper with white spindly lines running through it. Some bits of sparkly dust glinted off it in the sun.
我们漫无目的地走着。天气很热。我们寻找阴凉处。他在一堆石头旁停了下来，那是白色尖头栅栏前的门标。他用双手捡起其中一块石头。又大又粗糙，布满了盐和胡椒般的白色细纹。太阳下闪烁着些许火花。
He stood holding it to his chest for a moment and then, looking around, gently put it down somewhere else, less than a foot away.
他把它贴在胸口站了一会儿，然后环顾四周，轻轻地把它放到了不到一英尺远的别处。
There, doesn't it look better now? He said. He looked satisfied, relieved at what he had done. I fought back irritation and wondered at what this meant to him. I guessed it was because he had done something. Sometimes just doing any one thing can make you feel better. It doesn't matter what.
瞧，现在看起来是不是好多了？他说。他看起来很满意，对自己所做的事情感到如释重负。我克制住心中的烦躁，想知道这对意味着什么。我猜是因为他做了某件事。有时仅仅做某事就能让你感觉好一点。是什么并不重要。
The look on his face picking up the rock, moving it, walking, it all made me so tired.
他捡起石头、移动它、走路时脸上的表情，这一切都让我感到无比疲惫。
Do you want to turn around? I said.
你想转回去吗？我说。
He said, yes, looking anxious again. Then no, knowing he had said the wrong thing.
他说，想，神情再次变得焦虑。然后又说不，意识到自己说错了话。
We sat on a mound of tall, reedy grass down from a tree. It was cooler.
我们在树下一堆高耸的芦苇草上坐了下来。那里凉快些。
I said, what are you thinking?
我说，你在想什么？
He said, tall grass, and looked at me. His eyes were wide open.
他说，高高的草，看着我。他的眼睛睁得很大。
I smiled at him. He said things like that and I loved him. He lounged and I sat and picked up twigs and pushed them into the soft, moist ground, reaching for pieces of bark. Different mottled surfaces, rough, but warm and comforting in my hands. I placed them carefully between the twigs.
我对他笑了笑。他说出那样的话，我爱他。他懒洋洋地躺着，我坐着捡起树枝，把它们推入柔软潮湿的泥土中，伸手去拿树皮碎片。不同的斑驳表面，粗糙，但在我手里却温暖而舒适。我小心地把它们放在树枝之间。
He said, what are you doing?
他说，你在做什么？
I said, I'm making a pile for a little animal to find and to use. And besides, the bark is so pretty.
我说，我在堆一个小堆，好让小动物发现并使用。而且，树皮太漂亮了。
He said, I'm breaking up little pieces of twig and hiding them around. He laughed edgy and said, yeah, that's me. Hiding stuff like nobody could see.
他说，我把小树枝折断，藏在各处。他紧张地笑了笑说，是的，那就是我。像没人在看一样藏东西。
I wondered if he loved me. If e really loved me. That morning in bed he said, I love you. I love you.
我想知道他是否爱我。他是否真的爱我。那天早上在床上，他说，我爱你。我爱你。
But when I said, then why? He couldn't answer.
但当我问，那为什么？他无法回答。
Now he said, I like you so much. So very much. And I noticed he didn't say love.
现在他说，我非常非常喜欢你。我注意到他没有说爱。
It didn't matter so much, I just looked at the words for a while. I looked at the sound the words made after they were said. I knew he loved me, but that he didn't know what that meant. And the truth was that I didn't either. And I wasn't sure that it made any difference.
这没那么重要，我只是看着那些话许久。我看着这些话被说出口后产生的余音。我知道他爱我，但他不知道那意味着什么。事实是，我也不知道。而且我不确定这是否有什么不同。
We walked back to the cabin holding each other. It was warm again. Our bodies were wet against each other. The wet felt good.
我们互相依偎着走回小屋。天气又变热了。我们的身体贴在一起，感觉湿润。那种潮湿感很好。
We walked up to the house. I held his hand tightly for a moment. He let go too quickly and I pressed my lips together.
我们走到房子前。我紧紧地握着他的手片刻。他很快松开了，我抿紧了嘴唇。
I watched him walk up the steps, push open the screen door. The breeze caught the door and it swung for a moment back and forth. I waited outside for him to lock up.
我看着他走上台阶，推开纱门。微风吹动了门，它来回摇晃了一会儿。我在外面等着他锁门。
Well, coming up in part two of our program, less gloomy stories. Not so many sad stories of yearning. Instead, stories of love, love, love and sex, sex, sex, and marriage. Stay with us, it's Your Radio Playhouse.
好的，在我们的节目第二部分，将是一些没那么阴郁的故事。不会有那么多关于渴望的悲伤故事。相反，会有关于爱、爱、爱，以及性、性、性和婚姻的故事。留在这里，这是《你的广播剧场》。
Act two, it's Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass.
第二幕，这里是《你的广播剧场》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Sex. What would a Valentine's Day show be without sex? And we're going to start with this story of sexual discovery put together by audio artist Gregory Whitehead, who lives in Massachusetts.
性。如果没有性，情人节节目会是什么样？我们将从这个由居住在马萨诸塞州的音频艺术家格雷戈里·怀特海德制作的关于性发现的故事开始。
Just a little warning here, some of the material in the next two stories might be unsuitable for younger listeners.
一个小小的警告，接下来的两个故事中的一些内容可能不适合年轻听众。
I was 13 and he was 15. And we were going to go to the movies. We went to the Blue Star Shopping Center on Route 22. To see Live or Let Die . And I think his mother drove us. And we sat in the movie next to each other and he didn't make a move. And nothing happened. And then his father came and picked us up and drove us back to his house.
我13岁，他15岁。我们打算去看电影。我们去了22号公路上的蓝星购物中心去看《生死关头》。我想是他母亲开车送我们去的。我们并排坐在电影院里，他什么也没做。什么也没发生。然后他父亲来接我们，把我们送回了他家。
So he said, do you want to come up to my room? And as we went into his room, he closed the door and said, we're not allowed to lock our doors in my house. So otherwise he would have locked the door.
所以他说，你想去我的房间吗？当我们进入他房间时，他关上门说，在我家我们不允许锁门。不然他肯定会锁上的。
This is really awful.
这真的很糟糕。
So I don't know, he like roamed around and was showing me stuff. And I was just being sort of polite. And showing me all his toys and junk and silly things that he had. And then proceeded to make the moves. make the big moves on me. And I was just very innocent. And he was very aggressive. And just started kissing me and then just said, take off your shirt.
所以我不知道，他就像在房间里转来转去，给我看他的东西。我只是礼貌地应付。他给我看他所有的玩具、垃圾和傻东西。然后就开始有所行动了。他对我采取了大动作。我非常天真。而他非常有侵略性。只是开始吻我，然后说，脱掉你的衬衫。
And so I'm sitting there thinking, well, the door is unlocked. And he said, well, he had a little sister who was pestering us. So eventually I figured someone will just walk in. And he's likes well, no. And asks me, do I want to see it? And of course, I want to see it. I want to know what it looks like. But at the same time, I feel like I'm in this incredibly ominous, dangerous situation.
所以我坐在那里想，好吧，门没锁。他说他有个小妹妹一直在缠着我们。所以我最终想，肯定会有人闯进来的。他喜欢说，不，并问我，你想看吗？当然，我想看。我想知道它看起来是什么样。但同时，我觉得自己处于一个极其阴森、危险的境地。
It's pornographic. I'm just a little girl. Now I know how much of a little girl I was. I was just 13. I mean, 13 is young.
这很色情。我只是个小女孩。现在我知道我当时有多像个小女孩了。我才13岁。我的意思是，13岁还很小。
But there it was. It was this mindless thing. And I thought, well--
但它就在那儿。这是个无脑的东西。我心想，嗯——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的人声]
So yeah, so he whips it out. And we both sit and we look at it.
所以是的，他把它掏了出来。我们俩坐着看着它。
And he says, well, do you want to touch it? And I didn't want to. But I did. It was just horrible and dirty. More dirty than anything I've ever done since, even trying to be dirty.
他问，你想摸摸它吗？我不想。但我还是摸了。它真是又恶心又肮脏。比我后来做过的任何事都脏，即使是试着变坏的时候。
It was clinical. And I felt like I was being experimented upon. And the worse thing was that I was so passive. And I did what I was told because I was a good girl.
它很临床。我觉得自己像个实验品。最糟糕的是我当时太被动了。我照他说的做了，因为我是个乖女孩。
It was like a game to him. Now that I'm older, now that I think about it, it was a game. It wasn't playful. It was a very sophisticated game. It was a game of erotic and it wasn't loving to-- it was just a nightmare,
对他来说这像个游戏。现在我老了，回想起来，那确实是个游戏。那不是玩耍，那是一个非常复杂的游戏。那是一个色情游戏，而且根本不爱——那只是场噩梦。
to coerce someone or to seduce someone. To seduce a little girl. It was as if he were 40.
强迫某人或引诱某人。引诱一个小女孩。他表现得好像他已经40岁了。
So here was this--
所以这是——
But there it was. This mindless thing.
但它就在那儿。这个无脑的东西。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的人声]
So he could like make it move and flop around all by itself.
所以他能让它自己动，甩来甩去。
It was such a horrible situation. This spineless thing. But it has a mind of its own and a body of its own, so it moved around. And I was just appalled. I had no idea that this is what happened. That you could like make it move, all by itself without touching. And then it just stood up. It stood straight up. It was like wagging. It was like his little ventriloquist dummy that he could make talk to me.
这真是一个可怕的情况。这个无脊椎的东西。但它有自己的意识和身体，所以它四处移动。我感到震惊。我不知道会发生这种事。你竟然可以让它动，完全不需要触摸。然后它就立起来了。它直直地立了起来。它在摇摆。就像他的小腹语木偶，他能让它对我说话。
It wasn't playful and finally--
它不是玩耍，最后——
It wasn't erotic.
它不是色情的。
His sister was knocking at the door. It wasn't loving. We put our clothes back on and--
他妹妹在敲门。那不是爱。我们穿回衣服，然后——
My mother came and picked us up. And I walked outside on his nice suburban lawn. And his mother was there and my mother was talking to his mother. And I stared at our mothers.
我母亲来接我们。我走到他漂亮的郊区草坪上。他母亲在那里，我母亲在和他母亲聊天。我盯着我们的母亲。
But then I knew I could never tell--
但当时我知道我永远不能告诉——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的人声]
I just wanted to get out of there. To get to a safe place.
我只想离开那里。去一个安全的地方。
But then I knew I could never tell anyone what had happened. So I could never be in a safe place.
但当时我知道我永远不能告诉任何人发生了什么事。所以我永远无法身处安全之地。
One of the associate producers here at Your Radio Playhouse , Nancy Updike, has this small sociological discovery about sex in America.
《你的广播剧场》的制片助理南希·厄普代克，有一个关于美国性生活的小小的社会学发现。
It's an odd sort of discovery about one of the most politicized aspects of sex in America: condom use.
这是一个关于美国最政治化的性行为领域之一的奇怪发现：避孕套的使用。
I just want to know, am I the last one to know about this? Because the first time I had sex without a condom was only a few months ago. I was dating this 21-year-old Irish boy with a creamy body and a big mouth. After the first time we skipped it, we never used a condom. At the time, I was living with my best friend, Sarah. She and I were sort of married and we told each other everything.
我只是想知道，我是最后一个知道这件事的人吗？因为我第一次不使用避孕套发生性关系是在几个月前。我当时在和一个21岁的爱尔兰男孩约会，他身体白皙，嘴巴很大。第一次不戴套之后，我们就再也没用过了。当时，我和我最好的朋友莎拉住在一起。我们就像夫妻一样，什么都说。
One morning leaving my lovely boyfriend sprawled out and sleeping, I went next door to Sarah's room and sat down on her bed.
一天早上，把可爱的男友留在床上睡觉，我走到隔壁莎拉的房间，坐在她的床上。
So how's the sex? She smiled.
“性生活怎么样？”她笑着问。
Fun, I said. Not the greatest ever, but vigorous and sort of sweet. Pause.
“很有趣，”我说。“不是有史以来最棒的，但很有活力，而且挺甜美的。”停顿。
I wanted to tell her about the whole condom thing because I knew she was assuming we were using them, mistaking us every day for good, righteous people instead of the bad, irresponsible people we, in fact, were. And the longer it went on, the more it felt like I was lying.
我想告诉她关于避孕套的事，因为我知道她以为我们在用，每天都误以为我们是正派、正直的人，而不是事实上那糟糕、不负责任的人。进行得越久，我就越觉得自己在撒谎。
We're not using condoms, I blurted it out, looking down. There was a long pause.
“我们没用避孕套，”我脱口而出，低下头。长时间的停顿。
Josh and I aren't using them either, she said.
“乔什和我也没用，”她说。
I looked up. We stared at each other for a second and we burst out laughing. It may be hard to convey the strange giddiness of this moment to anyone who didn't go to college in the late '80s and early '90s. For Sarah and me, and for our girlfriends, safe sex was the marker of the modern, straight, post-AIDS feminist. She has sex with who she wants and when she wants, but she always protects herself. It was about self-respect and it was about being down with the cause. Sisters knew that sisters used condoms.
我抬起头。我们对视了一秒钟，然后大笑起来。对于任何没有在80年代末和90年代初上大学的人来说，可能很难体会那一刻那种奇怪的眩晕感。对莎拉和我，以及我们的女性朋友来说，安全性行为是现代、正统、后艾滋时代女性主义者的标志。她想和谁做爱就和谁做爱，想什么时候做就什么时候做，但她总是保护自己。这关乎自尊，关乎支持这项事业。姐妹们都知道，姐妹们使用避孕套。
Well, that was then. Here are some of the sisters now.
好吧，那是当时。现在看看这些姐妹们。
I don't think anybody uses them anymore.
我觉得没人在用它了。
I used them-- oh my god-- many moons ago.
我用过——噢，天哪——那是很久很久以前的事了。
Well, kind of.
嗯，算是吧。
We use them once in a while like right around the time that I know that I'm ovulating.
我们偶尔用一次，比如我知道我排卵的那段时间。
Statistics seem to indicate that, in fact, very few women are practicing safe sex. Nationwide, only about 20% of currently sexually active women report using condoms. And one out of five of those condom-using women hadn't used one the last time they had intercourse.
统计数据似乎表明，事实上，很少有女性在实践安全性行为。在全国范围内，只有大约20%的性活跃女性报告使用避孕套。而那些使用避孕套的女性中，五分之一的人在上次性交时并没有使用。
Gay men, in contrast, seem more careful. But even here, a San Francisco survey showed only half of gay men saying they use a condom every time they have sex.
相比之下，男同性恋者似乎更谨慎。但即使如此，旧金山的一项调查显示，只有一半的男同性恋者说他们每次发生性关系时都会使用避孕套。
Interestingly, these studies, the most current according to the Centers for Disease Control, are four years old, and are based on data collected four years before that, at the height of my alleged safe sex vigilance and that of my friends. So what now seems clear is that a massive nationwide campaign to shape our sex lives failed. And no one is talking about the fact that it failed.
有趣的是，这些根据美国疾病控制中心的最新的研究，已经是四年前的数据了，而且是基于四年前收集的数据，正是在我所谓安全性行为警觉性和我的朋友们警觉性的高峰期。所以现在很明显的是，一场旨在塑造我们性生活的全国性运动失败了。而且没人讨论它失败了这一事实。
Most of us are not practicing safe sex and never did. At least not in that every time, for the whole time, no exceptions way that safe sex as we knew it was all about. And now, nearly everyone I know seems paralyzed in this weird state that's part shame at what we see as laziness about using condoms, and part stubborn attachment to our secret decision not to use them as often as we feel we should.
我们大多数人并没有实践安全性行为，也从来没实践过。至少不是那种“每次、全程、无例外”的安全性行为。而现在，我认识的每个人似乎都陷入了一种奇怪的状态，一部分是为我们所谓的“懒于使用避孕套”感到羞耻，另一部分则是顽固地坚持我们内心关于不那么频繁使用避孕套的秘密决定。
For instance, I started out scared about not using condoms with my cute Irish boyfriend and had to keep rationalizing what we were doing by reminding myself that he was a drunk, not a junkie. And that he'd gotten head for a boy only once and hadn't liked it.
例如，我一开始因为没和可爱的爱尔兰男友使用避孕套而感到害怕，不得不不断为我们的行为合理化，提醒自己他是个酒鬼，而不是吸毒者。而且他只给一个男孩口交过一次，而且并不喜欢。
But then fear faded to guilt, and now I don't even think the guilt makes sense. I'm not using condoms and my women friends are not using condoms because when we look around, we are not dying of this disease, and neither is anyone we're sleeping with. And it's been that way for 10 years now. Heterosexual, non-drug-using women simply have not, as a group, become the much-feared second wave of the AIDS epidemic as we were always being warned in college that we would.
但随后恐惧变成了内疚，现在我甚至觉得内疚都没有意义了。我不用避孕套，我的女性朋友们也不用，因为当我们环顾四周时，我们并没有死于这种疾病，我们发生关系的任何人也没有。这种情况已经持续10年了。异性恋、不吸毒的女性作为一个群体，并没有像我们在大学里一直被警告的那样，成为令人恐惧的艾滋病疫情的第二波爆发。
Only 8% of all diagnosed AIDS cases in the United States are from heterosexual contact, according to the CDC. But we keep calling ourselves lazy, my friends and I, I think because we're feeling like bad feminists. Giving up safe sex means giving up that solidarity we believed in back when it seemed like we were all going to be at risk together-- gay men, straight women, women across lines of race, and class, and age, all of us united against a single, deadly common enemy.
根据美国疾控中心的数据，美国所有诊断出的艾滋病病例中，只有8%是通过异性恋传播的。但我们还是管自己叫“懒惰”，我觉得那是因为我们觉得自己是糟糕的女性主义者。放弃安全性行为意味着放弃我们在相信我们要共同承担风险时所信仰的那种团结——男同性恋者、异性恋女性，跨越种族、阶级和年龄的女性，我们所有人团结一致对抗一个单一的、致命的共同敌人。
Five years later, I think it's only a matter of time before the phrase, "No glove, no love" sounds to us the way "Sisterhood is powerful" sounds to our mothers.
五年后，我想，“没有套就没有爱”这句话听起来像“姐妹力量大”听起来像我们母亲那辈的事，只是时间问题而已。
[MUSIC- "FORBIDDEN LOVE" BY MADONNA]
[音乐 - 麦当娜的《禁忌之爱》]
Act three, A Wedding.
第三幕：婚礼。
Shakespeare ends his comedies with weddings, and it's easy to see why. You want a moment of joy, of hope at the end of any program that touches on the idea of love.
莎士比亚以婚礼结束他的喜剧，原因很容易理解。在任何触及爱情观念的节目结尾，你都需要一个充满喜悦和希望的时刻。
OK, hold his hand. All right, now whatever I say in English, you're going to tell him in Spanish.
好吧，握住他的手。好的，我现在用英语说的任何话，你都要用西班牙语告诉他。
If you walk downstairs in Chicago's City Hall, you take the escalator down when you walk in that front door on whatever street that is. If you walk downstairs and you turn right, you come to marriage court. It costs $10. There's a big sign saying right up front you can't offer the judge a gratuity. And you know, you get the license down the hall and then there's a one-day waiting period, like if you buy a handgun or something. They don't want people rushing into it.
如果你走进芝加哥市政厅，从那条街的前门走进去，你会坐自动扶梯下楼。如果你下楼向右转，你就到了婚姻法庭。费用是10美元。门口有个大牌子写着你不能给法官小费。你知道，你在走廊领证，然后有一个为期一天的等待期，就像你买手枪一样。他们不希望人们操之过急。
12,530 people were married in this court last year. That's more than any other place in Illinois, as best as anybody can figure.
去年有12530人在这个法庭结婚。据任何人估计，这比伊利诺伊州的任何其他地方都要多。
I'm going to ask them about eight questions. Now, I don't want them to answer each question. When I'm all done with the eight questions-- ocho-- then I'll say to him, OK, Francisco, what is your answer? And he'll answer once. Tell him that.
我会问他们大约八个问题。我不希望他们回答每个问题。等我问完八个问题（ocho）后，我会对他说：“好的，弗朗西斯科，你的回答是什么？”然后他回答一次。告诉他这一点。
Wednesday morning Francisco and Arminia Orosco stood before Judge Arthur Rosenblum. Arminia spoke English, but Francisco didn't. And although is was happening in a basement office with dingy carpet, and although the groom was in jeans with a Coors belt buckle and a leather jacket, and although they brought no witnesses, and although both of them were planning on going to work after the wedding-- her at an insurance office and him at a record store-- there was still something moving about watching her translate the vows, looking in the eyes of her husband-to-be. That is, once they actually got started.
周三上午，弗朗西斯科和阿米尼亚·奥罗斯科站在亚瑟·罗森布鲁姆法官面前。阿米尼亚说英语，但弗朗西斯科不说。尽管这一切发生在一个铺着破旧地毯的地下室办公室里，尽管新郎穿着牛仔裤、带着库尔斯皮带扣和皮夹克，尽管他们没带证人，尽管他们两人都计划在婚礼后去上班——她在保险公司，他在唱片店——看着她翻译誓言，凝视着未婚夫眼睛的样子，依然有一些动人的东西。也就是说，一旦他们真正开始的话。
OK, ready? Here we go.
好的，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。
Francisco, do you take her to be your wife, and to live together with her as husband and wife? What are you looking at me for? Translate it.
弗朗西斯科，你愿意娶她为妻，并作为夫妻共同生活吗？你看着我干什么？翻译啊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And live together with her as husband and wife.
并作为夫妻共同生活。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Do you promise to love her, honor her, and respect her?
你承诺爱她、尊重她并敬重她吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Do you promise to be her friend?
你承诺做她的朋友吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Do you promise to take care of her whether she's sick or whether she's well?
你承诺照顾她，无论生病还是健康吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Judge Rosenblum looks in their eyes as he does the ceremony. He doesn't have a piece of paper or anything with the script. And after both of them did their vows, Judge Rosenblum gave a little speech about the wedding rings, about how they symbolize an endless love, an endless friendship. And both of them put on the rings.
罗森布鲁姆法官在举行仪式时会凝视他们的眼睛。他没有拿着脚本纸或类似的东西。在他们两人宣读誓言后，罗森布鲁姆法官发表了一段关于结婚戒指的小演讲，谈到它们如何象征着无尽的爱和无尽的友谊。他们两人都戴上了戒指。
All right, you're Senor Esposa. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
好的，现在你们是夫妻了（Senor Esposa）。[说西班牙语]
A big embrace, he says.
他说，拥抱一下。
Beso, beso.
吻一下，吻一下。
Kiss, kiss. So they do.
亲吻，亲吻。于是他们照做了。
Judge Rosenblum has done a few things to make weddings in city hall a little more human. He's replaced the generic hotel art in the office with a Norman Rockwell print.
罗森布鲁姆法官做了一些事情，让市政厅的婚礼更具人性化。他把办公室里通用的酒店艺术品换成了诺曼·洛克威尔的版画。
One whole wall of his office is lined with snapshots of happy couples, him in the middle. In this office, you see the whole range of couples, all ages and races, all incomes. Though a lot of people come to City Hall because it's so cheap. And the full range of happy and unhappy couples.
他办公室的一整面墙上都贴满了幸福夫妇的照片，他就在中间。在这个办公室里，你看到了各种各样的夫妻，所有年龄和种族，所有收入水平。虽然很多人因为便宜才来市政厅。这里还有幸福和不幸福夫妇的全部范围。
Joan Healey is the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] good humor, completely wonderful woman who greets you when you walk into the office and arrive at the front window. She's the one who takes your $10. And she says that she sees some couples she frankly has to worry about a little.
琼·希利是一位在市政厅前台接待你、非常有幽默感、绝对了不起的女士。就是她收你的10美元。她说，她看到有些夫妇，坦率地说，她不得不有点担心。
I really think, walk away. Walk away. It's a long life together, long life together.
我真的在想，离开吧。离开吧。生活在一起很漫长，漫长的生活。
And what are you seeing when you think that? What are they doing?
当你这么想的时候，你看到了什么？他们在做什么？
I get a funny feeling in the tone of voice that they use to one another. This is kidding on the square, you are seeing this. And you're kind of hurting that person. Or just maybe sitting in a chair. If one will sit, go and sit in the chair, and the one that I kind of think is not the nice one would probably go sit in another chair on the other side of the room. Not really even wanting to be together, things like that. Just kind of shake your head and say-- by the time you get up to the escalator, the top of the escalator, I hope they're still together.
我从他们对彼此说话的语气中有一种奇怪的感觉。这种“开玩笑”背后其实是认真的，你看到了。你觉得你在伤害那个人。或者只是可能坐在椅子上。如果一个人坐下，去另一张椅子坐，我心想那个人可能不是那个好人，大概会去房间另一边坐另一张椅子。不想在一起，诸如此类的。只是摇摇头说——等到你上了电梯，上了自动扶梯顶端，我希望他们还能在一起。
In his chambers, between weddings, Judge Rosenblum reads and smokes a pipe. He was out til midnight the night before I visited in his regular gin rummy game. He's 79, married twice, but not currently married. He says that there's nothing the rabbi could have said to him under the marriage canopy when he got married that would've been useful advice. Each marriage runs the course it's supposed to, he says. It's just dumb luck. Nobody can really tell you anything.
在法官办公室里，婚礼间隙，罗森布鲁姆法官会看书抽烟斗。我拜访他前一晚，他直到午夜才结束他的常规金拉米牌局。他79岁，结过两次婚，目前未婚。他说，当他结婚时，拉比在婚礼下对他说的任何话都不会是有用的建议。每一段婚姻都有它注定的历程，他说。这纯粹是运气。没人能真正告诉你什么。
Some should marry, some should not. Some do, some will last. Some won't last. That's true of all life in anything, right?
有些人应该结婚，有些人不应该。有些人会结，有些人能持久。有些不会持久。这适用于生活中的任何事，对吧？
Joan, let me ask you something? Why do people get married?
琼，让我问你点事？为什么人们要结婚？
Oh, for various reasons. Some for love, some for money. Some I don't know why.
哦，原因各异。有些为了爱，有些为了钱。有些我不知道为什么。
Well, you married for money, right?
好吧，你是为了钱才结婚的，对吧？
Oh, yes. Can't you tell?
哦，是的。你看不出来吗？
If couples seem interested, Judge Rosenblum will pull a book out of his upper left-hand desk drawer and read a little bit. The book is Kahlil Gibran's The Prophet.
如果夫妇看起来很感兴趣，罗森布鲁姆法官会从办公桌左上角的抽屉里拿出一本书读一小段。那本书是卡里·纪伯伦的《先知》。
And this book is a great allegory. An allegory is a story like a parable. And what it does is it tells you something which really means something else.
这本书是一则伟大的寓言。寓言就像一个比喻故事。它的作用是告诉你一些真正意味着其他含义的东西。
He turns to the chapters on love and marriage.
他翻到关于爱和婚姻的章节。
I'll only read the parts that are worldwide known.
我只读那些广为人知的部分。
But if in your fear you would seek only love's peace and love's pleasure, then it is better for you that you cover your nakedness and pass out of love's threshing floor. In the seasonless world where you shall laugh, but not with all of your laughter, and weep, but not with all of your tears."
“但如果你们因恐惧而只想寻求爱的平静和爱的快乐，那么最好掩盖你们的赤裸，离开爱的脱粒场。走向那个无季节的世界，在那里你们可以欢笑，但不是尽情欢笑；可以哭泣，但不是尽情哭泣。”
It can take away your faith in the romance of marriage to see 12,000 of them in a year. But Judge Rosenblum says he sees his share of truly happy couples in this job.
看到一年里发生12000次婚姻，可能会削弱你对婚姻浪漫的信仰。但罗森布鲁姆法官说，他在这份工作中看到了属于他的那份真正幸福的夫妇。
The other woman working up front, Michelle Roberts, says that despite this job, she's still glad to be married when she goes home at night.
前台工作的另一位女士米歇尔·罗伯茨说，尽管从事这份工作，她晚上回家时仍然很高兴自己已经结婚了。
And every day, dozens more arrive to take their vows. Some dressed in formal wear, some in jeans. Many with children in tow.
每天都有几十对新人赶来宣读誓言。有的穿着礼服，有的穿着牛仔裤。许多人带着孩子。
Valentine's Day turns out to be the busiest day of the year here. 145 marriages last Valentine's Day. The halls were jammed. The elevator jammed. The escalator jammed with people who couldn't wait to get married on the holiday of love.
情人节成了这里一年中最忙的一天。去年的情人节有145场婚礼。大厅拥挤不堪。电梯堵塞。自动扶梯上挤满了迫不及待想在爱的节日结婚的人们。
Well, before we end our show, there's a song that we've actually been saving to play for Valentine's Day. We recorded this back around Christmas. And these are kids at the Daniel J. Nellum Youth Services in Chicago. And they sing this little song that they made up, a little crush song. They include Antwone Robinson, Warren Harris, Sean Cook, Edward G. Robinson, Junior, Willie Weddington, Curtis Perry, and Nate Settles. Here's their song.
好了，在结束节目之前，有一首歌我们实际上一直留着要在情人节播放。我们是在圣诞节前后录制的。这是芝加哥丹尼尔·J·内勒姆青少年服务中心的孩子们。他们唱了这首他们自创的小歌，一首关于暗恋的歌。他们包括安特旺·鲁滨逊、沃伦·哈里斯、肖恩·库克、爱德华·G·鲁滨逊二世、威利·韦丁顿、柯蒂斯·佩里和内特·塞特尔斯。这是他们的歌。
Tonight's program was produced by Dolores Wilbur and by myself, with Alix Spiegel, Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rockland and Mr. Paul Tough.
今晚的节目由多洛莉丝·威尔伯和我本人制作，艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔、彼得·克洛尼和南希·厄普代克参与制作。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·洛克兰和保罗·塔夫先生。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. That's a really good name to mess up during the credits.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。在片尾字幕中弄错这个名字真是太棒了。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you would care to buy a tape of this or our other Radio Playhouse programs, call us. Call us, call us at WBEZ 312-832-3380.
如果您想购买本节目或其他广播剧场节目的录音带，请致电我们。致电我们，拨打WBEZ电台 312-832-3380。
You can email us with any comments or thoughts and we will email you back. Our address, [email protected] .
您可以给我们发送电子邮件，提出任何意见或想法，我们将回复您。我们的地址是 [email protected]。
And do you remember that really smart, amazing guy in the iron lung? You can actually email him. His name is Mark O'Brien if you want to chat with him. And his email address is marko-- M-A-R-K-O-- @well.com.
还记得那个生活在铁肺里的极其聪明、了不起的人吗？您可以给他发电子邮件。他的名字叫马克·奥布莱恩，如果您想和他聊天的话。他的电子邮件地址是 marko-- M-A-R-K-O-- @well.com。
We, this Radio Playhouse program, we broadcast proudly from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more stories of this here American life, I'm Ira Glass.
我们，这个广播剧场节目，自豪地从芝加哥WBEZ电台播出。下周我们将带回更多关于美国生活的故事，我是艾拉·格拉斯。